-Ladies and gentlemen,
we present to you
two brains working as one --
the first brain
providing the answer,
the second brain
revealing the question.
It´s time for a brainstorm!
[ Thunder crashing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♫♫
[ Laughter and cheers ]
-White out.
♫♫
-What does Mike Pence say
when he leaves a party?
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Thunder crashing ]
♫♫
-"Young Sheldon."
-Who does my mom think
the most popular rapper is?
[ Thunder crashing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♫♫
-"American Horror Story."
-Describe the bathroom
at Chipotle.
[ Laughter ]
[ Thunder crashing ]
[ Applause ]
♫♫
-Wax on, wax off.
[ Light laughter ]
♫♫
[ Laughter ]
-What does Ted Cruz do
when he logs on to Twitter?
[ Laughter ]
[ Thunder crashing ]
[ Applause ]
♫♫
-Pork butt and Snoop Dogg.
-Name two things
that smoke for 12 hours.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Thunder crashing ]
[ Audience cheers ]
-"Donnie Darko."
♫♫
-What does Trump say
when he wants his butler
to turn off the lights?
"Donnie Darko."
[ Thunder crashing ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
♫♫
-Janeane Garofalo.
-How does a Starbucks barista
spell "Jake Gyllenhaal"?
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Thunder crashing ]
-This has been "Brainstorm."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Stronger" hits theaters
September 22nd.
We´ll be right back
with Dr. Jane Goodall.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Thunder crashing ]
♫♫